[Applaudissements]
richer a la patate chaude ce sera de
chine en fait ruch et tout j'adore avoir
perruque dans ce film en indochine a
adoré alors attention la patate chaude
c'est très simple des questions va
démarrer par bertrand elle est chaude et
la fiat comme son nom l'indiqué 100
secondes dès que vous avez la bonne
réponse des lois de passer la patate ont
fait un tour complet et ensuite vous l'a
passée à qui vous voulez
nabila joue nabila pas se retrouver en
nicola sirkis elle joue elle avec
d'accord j'aime pas gizeh
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas mal hein c'est pas qui c'est
c'est pas qui c'est c'est un vieux
chanteur
c'est lui qui était si vous regardez
regardez c'est lui voilà c'est votre
style à petit va très bien mais c'est
vrai que c'est un grand il a 50 ans 50
50 ans a battu aujourd'hui on entend
même d'ukraine a même dit à la cie
autant attention la patate
[Rires]
et vous savez quoi on va la faire dans
une seconde cette patate chose je vous
le dit nabila va participer avec nous à
la patate chaude ira bertrand chamerois
qui va venir nous rejoindre bien sûr ya
camille combal qui viendra de voir c'est
la dernière de touche pas à mon poste on
a beaucoup beaucoup de surprises